Hey Youtubers it's Charlie and Marvel is getting
ready to announce the Director of the Doctor
Strange movie. Which pretty much confirms
it's going to be one of those mystery Phase
3 movies. The director is Scott Derrickson
who did this really creepy horror movie The
Exorcism of Emily Rose and Sinister with Ethan
Hawke. That doesn't mean Ethan Hawke is going
to be Doctor Strange, but this video will
be my Top 10 picks for who it should be.
Just as an update on Ant-Man, they haven't
found a new director yet, but the frontrunner
is Rawson Thurber, he's the guy who directed
Dodgeball. If you're finding me for the first
time, I do bonus Marvel and DC videos every
week. Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
There are links for my social accounts where
I post updates on what each video is going
to be.
So Doctor Strange, before we talk about actors,
we have to talk about what kind of a movie
this is going to be. It's not just going to
be Iron Man with Magic. The vibe of the comics
will inform the vibe of the movie and the
person Marvel picks to play Doctor Strange.
The character at his core has the same call
to action that Tony Stark does, but where
Iron Man is a story that revolves around technology
and transparency, Doctor Strange is a really
Dark, Eerie exploration of the mind. And Demons,
lots of demons. Which kind of explains why
they would pick a director that did movies
about demons.
This has a real chance of being Marvel's first
big Horror Movie. and when I say Horror, I
mean Disney horror, not Eli Roth torture porn,
like Hostel. Imagine what that would look
like.
So when we think about actors we want to play
the role, we have to limit choices to people
who can do really dark horror movies and come
out looking like an Iron Man level hero. Just
look at him during Marvel's Infinity event
last year. I don't think he can even remember
the last time he smiled. Think about actors
who can make that kind of person appealing.
So here are my top 10 picks for Doctor Strange.
Number 10 - Jon Hamm
I feel like Jon Hamm is being considered for
every major troubled hero of a certain age.
He's done with Mad Men, even though they still
have 7 more episodes to air next year. They've
shot everything. So he's free to do more movies
now. Without making too many Don Draper analogies,
Hamm has been really good at making an unlikable
character very appealing. Stephen Strange
is a way bigger asshole than Tony Stark.
When he becomes Doctor Strange he's full on
zen. Which almost looks like the absence of
emotion. I'm just picturing that cold Don
Draper stare while he's whispering a spell.
Number 9 - Justin Theroux
He was rumored for the role a long time ago
and like Jon Hamm, he's played some darker
roles. He's got a strong comedy background,
but even the funny characters he's played
are super dark or downright evil.
He doesn't quite have the A-List appeal of
someone like Jon Hamm or some of the other
guys on my list, but I think he's a little
more versatile. There can be no Marvel film
without a little bit of humor. So just being
really depressing and good looking isn't going
to be enough.
The only thing that might keep him from doing
it is his new HBO series The Leftovers. He's
one of the stars. It's a Damon Lindelof Series
too with pretty good reviews. So I don't see
him dumping that for a Marvel Movie, but never
say never.
Number 8 - Kit Harington
One of two Game of Thrones actors on my list.
He's only just started to break out with some
big budget movies, but he's got the appeal
Marvel and Disney want for a movie this big.
And because he's relatively new they can get
him on the cheap. A opposed to someone like
Johnny Depp who's super expensive.
He's booked a movie in 2015 already, which
may or may not cause some schedule conflicts,
but if he can shoot other big movies and do
Game of Thrones at the same time. There's
no reason he couldn't shoot a Marvel movie.
Just for reference too, the unofficial release
date for the Doctor Strange movie is May 5th
2017. Which means they'd have to start shooting
it early in 2015. Most big movies like this
and Avengers 2 shoot about a year and a half
to two years in advance of their release dates.
That two year period after is what it usually
takes to do the special effects.
Number 7 - Hugh Laurie
This is an unlikely choice but I feel like
he would be so good for the part I had to
put him on my list. He's starring as the villain
in Brad Bird's Tomorrowland movie, which is
also Disney. It's scheduled for release May
22, 2017. I don't see Disney sticking a leading
actor in two of their films so close to each
other.
I would really like to see a slightly more
British version of Doctor House become sorcerer
supreme.
Number 6 - Keanu Reeves
He's gotten typecast in roles that are either
really heavy on psychology or supernatural
forces. But that's only because he can play
that flat dark emotion so well. I know a lot
of people give him crap for looking like he
doesn't act at all, but I think he'd be able
to pull of the Doctor Strange persona very
well. It's the Stephen Strange part I think
he'd have more trouble with. He does a lot
better when his characters aren't too intense,
like during Constantine when he's giving Rachel
Weisz the business about angels and demons.
Like he's so tired of everything, as if it's
no big deal.
Number 5 - Aiden Gillen
My other Game of Thrones actor on the list.
I feel like Littlefinger would make a great
Doctor Strange. Imagine a slightly less evil
version of Baelish, less pathology. He doesn't
look like someone who could open a 150 Million
Dollar Movie, but he's played so many amazing
dark characters so well I feel like he would
be a welcome addition to the Avengers roster.
When you look at them, the Hulk is really
the darkest character. But the Doctor Strange
persona is almost noir and Gillen has that
edge to him that Mark Ruffalo doesn't. Ruffalo
is just too adorable. I feel like Doctor Strange
can't just be a super handsome, typically
Hollywood looking actor. Which kind of explains
my next picks.
Number 4 - Viggo Mortensen
He's got the charisma to lead a big movie
Aragorn style, but he's someone that has a
really easy time disappearing into characters.
Meaning when we see him on screen we don't
think about Viggo, we think about the character
he's playing. That's another Johnny Depp problem,
which is why I think Marvel is going to find
an actor like Viggo who can go really dark
and still be charismatic without bringing
a ton of 'hollywood actor' baggage.
Plus, currently he hasn't booked any movies
beyond this year. So he's totally available.
And relatively affordable. The only issue
I see is that he'd have to sign the same 6
picture deal Marvel makes all of it's actors
sign. And I don't know if he'd want to commit
to something for the 8 plus years it would
take to fulfill that contract.
Even Chris Evans is ready to be doing other
things and he's only finished about half of
his contract.
Number 3 - Mads Mikkelsen
Anyone who watches Hannibal will understand
how amazing Mads is. Yes, he's a really really
awful guy on that show. But he has this very
subtle way about him that makes you both terrified
and hypnotized by him at the same time. Which
I think is what Marvel will want for Strange.
When you look at pictures like this, you can
clearly see how scary he looks despite being
a force for good.
You could almost say that Mads plays a food
magician on Hannibal. Even if he uses people
meats. But who else thinks that a Marvel hero
that scares the crap out of you would be amazing?
Number 2 - Benedict Cumberbatch
Probably one of the most in demand actors
in the world right now. His Sherlock character
is a good analog for Stephen Strange. A hyper
kinetic genius with a lot of pathos. He's
even starring in an animated movie called
Magik coming out July 4th 2016.
As much as I could argue why he's got all
the qualities I think make a perfect Doctor
Strange, I feel like his fans will just hear
Magic Sherlock. Which I don't think Marvel
would mind at all. A lot of who they cast
will depend on the Director. So as long as
Derrickson feels like Cumberbatch would fit
in one of his movies it's perfect.
Scheduling issues would be the only thing
that could kill this. They already had to
delay Sherlock Series 4 for two years because
he and Martin Freeman were so busy. Signing
up for 6 Marvel movies might not be something
he'd want to do.
But, giant asterisk. He did say he really
wanted to be a part of the new Star Wars movies
as a Jedi and that didn't quite work out.
So there is a precedent for him gravitating
towards these giant franchises.
and my Number 1 pick for Doctor Strange - Daniel
Bruhl
This might not be a guy you've seen or heard
of, but he's been a favorite of critics recently
in big movies like Rush, Inglorious Bastards
and Bourne Ultimatum. You do really need to
check him out in Rush. He plays exactly the
kind of anti-hero you would find in a Marvel
movie and he's got the benefit of being relatively
new. I think of his career as being a lot
like Mark Ruffalo's in that they've both done
some big movies but they're not like Robert
Downey Jr, their careers are still rising.
Downey on the other hand is at his peak. He
can't really go any higher.
Bruhl has this crazy intensity that I think
in combination with his appeal and availability
would make an amazing Doctor Strange.
But now it's your turn, let me know who you
think should play Doctor Strange.
They probably won't be doing a post-credits
scene for him in any of the movies for a long
time, but the Character was part of The Defenders
which Marvel is doing on Netflix in a couple
years. So that's probably where they'll debut
the character first.
One of the biggest issues is that it has to
be the right actor at the right time and a
lot of these people on my list book their
time years in advance. That's typically why
most big actors drop out of movies, because
they overlap with other mega movies they want
to make.
A really good example is Emily Blunt, who
was originally supposed to be Black Widow.
She had to turn down that role because of
a schedule conflict. I think we're all happy
with Scarlett Johansson, but if you want to
see a badass Emily Blunt, go see Edge of Tomorrow
this weekend. I'll be doing a review of that
on Thursday or Friday.
So, I'm still working on my next Star Wars
bonus video. I'll try to post it tomorrow.
Be sure to follow me on social if you want
updates for that. I'm usually pretty good
about giving status updates on new videos.
Twitter, Facebook, and all those other links
are at the bottom of the description.
Right now click here to learn about the top
5 stories I think they need to do for Doctor
Strange and click here to learn about Thanos
In Guardians Of The Galaxy
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!